calling in to the I guess this is news
category from the last few days it turns
out PlayStation users visit pornhub more
than Xbox users who near the adult
website released its yearly review this
week which is the thing it apparently
does and revealed the PlayStation users
make up forty six point nine percent off
their user base that's compared with
just thirty seven point nine percent who
identify as xbox users eight point nine
percent of users claim to be we gamers
I'll leave that innuendo up to you and
only one point three percent reported
gaming on a Nintendo 3ds the remaining
five percent with made up of PlayStation
Vita owners last year PlayStation users
made up slightly less of the pie with
forty percent of uses while Xbox users
were far more highly represented at
forty five point seven percent so
there's a bunch of information you
probably didn't need but now have enjoy
being the pornhub gamer traffic expert
of your friendship group and we'll have
a bunch more news for you on gamespot
you